start without the birthday boy
this is our afternoon session we have
two speakers the first speaker uh
professor shambo jeep bhattacharya from
oregon state university
she
graduated from our department in
2013
and we will talk about dependent
structures in network data
yeah uh thank you thank you for the
invitation to speak here so
uh
uh
giving means this is
i'm coming here after a long time means
away from i've been away from berkeley
for
more than seven years so
it's nice to be back
so
uh
the talk means uh
in this talk the work i will be
presenting i have two main collaborators
here
and one of my collaborators tishendo is
one of my long time long term
collaborators
so he's from city university of new york
he's a probabilist but trying to switch
to become a statistician
so
and show mendo is also a former student
of peter currently nice cycle qatar so
this they are the two main collaborators
but there are other collaborators for
all of the research works i will be
talking about uh throughout the
12 years talk so
this is a brief outline i don't know how
much i will be able to cover out of this
outline but i will go step by step and
if i feel that
i'm
running short of time then i will
probably skip some of the parts
so
so again means today we have been
talking yesterday also today also we
have been talking about network data
so we know
many of you know what network data is
network data most of the time is a
situation where the data is given in
form of a network essentially meaning
that you have
ah
the data is given in form of an
adjacency matrix related to the network
so you have
that as your data now the thing is here
as i mentioned the topic of the talk is
dependent structures in network data
so in a means first of all in network
data this entries adjacency matrix
entries they are dependent on each other
because that's what the network is
trying to capture a dependency pattern
between the nodes
oh i should remove this
so a dependency pattern between the
nodes that's what it is trying to
capture
so
so that's why we first of all need a
structure that captures this dependence
pattern
and then of course trying to extend that
trying to capture more and more
generalized pattern between different
forms of network data
so that's the goal by which we are going
into this kind of you can say building a
statistical inference framework for
network data sets
now
all of this started for me also like
many other people that were giving the
talks in this
in this conference like previously harry
mentioned and also jing mentioned today
in the morning means for me also when i
was doing phd here peter said that okay
i am doing some interesting work on
network statistics i will get you
involved let me first get out this paper
then after that
then after that i will get you involved
in that so
this was the work where peter and iu
they tried to build a framework a
statistical framework for network data
essentially trying to formalize the
dependence that is there in network data
in the adjacency matrix entries
so their idea was this non-parametric
view of network models
which
since then has been named given many
different names
uh it has been given exchangeable
network and graphone models or what the
peter gave the name to be non-parametric
network model all of different or
non-parametric latent variable models
several such names have been given and
previously also there were latin space
models which were also very similar to
this kind of models so
the essential idea is that corresponding
to the nodes you have a latent variable
the latent variables are usually unknown
and
based on whatever the values of the
latent variable are you have a
probability of edge formation between
two different nodes that's the simplest
idea so what you are doing is that you
are forming a conditional independent
structure here between the nodes by
which you are capturing the dependence
between the edges between difference
dependence between the adjacency matrix
edges
so
but so
essentially what you are ultimately
getting is a conditional independent
structure
now using this conditional independent
structure they are after in the next 12
or 13 years
an explosion of papers have occurred
there has been explosion of works that
has gone on using this
exchangeable structures or this kind of
latent space structures
now uh so
one type of the one type of extension
that we can look for here is that can we
extend this conditional independence
framework that means even accounting for
that means can we go beyond this
conditional independence setup so that
can be one type of extension that we can
look for here to account for the
dependence that is there between the
adjacency matrices
but
this is a model for single networks just
one network that is available to you as
a data but in the last
decade or so or even more there has been
an explosion
in network data sets also
so network data has been coming in not
only as a single network but a sequences
of networks for a collection of networks
so networks were not really many of the
times just one network data that was
observed or based on which this kind of
models were developed but network dot
data became sequences or collections
this kind of situations like we we could
get neuroscience data where there was a
sequence of brain networks that were
being observed in different animals or
we could get citation networks which was
changing over time
so this kind of situations occurred and
this is one of them my
i like this network really because it
has a nice changing pattern in the
network this is the voting patterns in
us congress where an age is drawn if two
congressmen both similarly on a single
bill and no age if there they vote
differently so as you can see
uh from 1950s for onwards to something
like 2011 the graph changed quite a bit
so there were
means these are republican democrats
there were quite a bit of
uh number of ages between the two
different groups in 1950s whereas in
2011 there is almost no ages between the
two groups
so that means these are all this is a
sequence of networks
and we can try to analyze whether there
is a change point in these
sequences of networks so that can be
another set of problems
yes
so the time goes this way like
the time goes the time goes like this
so
so this is also a very nice data set
which captures this kind of behavior
so
uh so yeah so that means that the
network data sets they also have been
evolving so not only that we want to
capture
more involved dependence within a single
network but we also want to capture
dependence in the sequences of networks
so
that's why like people have tried to
form this kind of more complex network
structures not only single networks but
this kind of multi-layer networks where
essentially you have a number of single
networks being combined into one large
structure
so previously gene was mentioning also
about this kind of multi-layer network
so
most general form of multi-layer
networks are that you have several
single networks each of those single
networks can have different node sets
there is connection between the nodes in
a single layer as well as between the
nodes of different layers
so you have say nodes here you say two
different layers here in one of the
layers you have four different nodes
there is connection between them in
another layer you have three nodes you
have connection between them and then
also you have connections between these
nodes
so
in this way that means that completely
different types of there are many
examples of this kind of behavior like
say in financial
financial network data there might be
this might be different financial uh
these can be different financial
institutions this can be different
financial measurements and they might be
connected in between them as well as
between themselves
so this kind of things can occur
similarly we can think of this as a
temporal network also that means
networks evolving over time
so
in the very general format therefore is
that there are several networks and then
there are connections between them thus
forming a multi-layer network
and more special cases of them are
things like what are known as multiplex
network where essentially the
nodes that are there they remain the
same
however
uh the
edge structure between each of these
layers they change so that is usually
called what is sometimes called as
multiplex networks but sometimes they
are also called multi-layer networks
uh because there isn't some interchange
in terminology many times
they can be also in temporal networks
can also be special cases of this where
one network is that means age structure
of a network is evolving over time and
that is captured in a temporal network
so any kind of sequential sequences of
networks can also be considered as a
multi layer network or a generalization
of a single network structure
so that's why
our goal then becomes twofold means at
least how that's how we are tackling the
problem of dependency network models
first of all there can be dependent in a
situation where you have a multi-layer
network you can have dependence across
layers in the network sequences
so we are considering here a situation
so of course we are going
we are considering the simpler networks
multiplex and temporal network we will
not be going for this very general
multi-layer networks
but we will be considering only
multiplex and temporal networks where
the node set remain the same but the say
edge set can change that kind of a
situation
so in that kind of a situation there can
be dependence across the network layers
that means adjacency
entry of an adjacency matrix in one
layer can be dependent on the entry of
the adjacency matrix in another layer
so there can be dependence across
multiple layers and this dependence we
are trying to model in two different
ways one is direct dependence of the
adjacency matrices
the second part is that the adjacency
matrix is being generated from some kind
of a latent model and the parameters of
those model they are the ones which are
related that means they follow a
stochastic process
and then the parameters are coming from
the stochastic blocker and the adjacency
matrices are being generated
conditionally independently so there is
still a conditional independent
structure in the second form and in this
form there is no conditional independent
structure in that way because the
adjacency matrix are related to each
other across time or across layers
so this is two type of generalization
that we will be considering
while considering dependence across
layers and then we will try to also go
for dependence in age formation that
means breaking the conditional
independent structure
so we'll try to break the conditional
independent structure using some ways
and then
try to form
even in a single network try to have a
structure which is not conditionally
independent and then trying to see how
we can do
whether we can do anything with those
kind of structures
so
that's how we are we will try to bring
in more dependence into network data
structures
uh of course as you can see means
there are very many facets to this
problem and then many facets to this the
way we are trying to tackle this problem
i will try to touch some of the aspects
uh not much and there is lot of works to
do also means we are only starting on
different aspects
so many of these so some of this works
we have submitted for publication some
of these works are ongoing some of the
works i will mention is future
directions so all sorts are there
okay
so the main questions that we will be
focusing on all of this
are these three main questions one is
community detection that means in
situations like this we will try to find
whether there are communities in these
networks
another will be change point detection
specifically if you have sequences of
networks whether we can find structural
breakpoints in the network sequences
and another type of problems will be
essentially the typical statistical
problem parameter estimation or in this
kind of situations there will be several
population parameters of the network
models can be formed whether we can
estimate those
so those will be the three main
categories of problem we can say because
all of these problems can have various
different
sub problems in them so these are the
three different categories of problem
that we will be interested in
now
let us go to first to the situation of
dependent layers that means network
sequences with dependent layers so we
will be considering a situation where
you have a multi-layer network
but the networks can be
dependent
so first thing so as i said we will be
forming two different types of
dependencies one is direct dependence of
adjacency matrices and other is the
dependence of the model parameters okay
so let me first tackle the problem of uh
dependence of adjacency matrices
so forming this dependence in itself
is a difficult thing so so for this we
had two additional collaborators or
students you can say so these were
master students from indian statistical
institute kolkata so by now they have
all joined as phd student in one is in
upend another is in column b i think
currently so uh
so but they
they helped us quite a bit doing
simulations and things like that in this
projects
so okay so the dependent layer formation
the formulation that we will be
considering here is this very simple one
because we started we wanted to start
with something simple because currently
there is not much work in this domain
where there is this kind of dependency
network structures
so the formulation that we considered
you can consider this as a some kind of
a lazy stochastic process that
essentially means that
in each of the adjacency matrices will
be equal to the adjacency matrix of the
previous time point with some
probability and with some probability
you will be generating a new adjacency
matrix independently
so the the dependence here comes because
you might be repeating the same
adjacency matrix so that's how the
dependence is coming here
and the probability
alpha here the probability with which
you are keeping the same
the adjacency matrix from the previous
time point is alpha and the probability
with which you are generating a new
adjacency matrix independently that is
one minus alpha
now in the situation of completely
independent situation
in that case this alpha will be equals
to zero that means you have always you
are independently generating uh another
adjacency matrix and this is the format
that is mostly used nowadays so like the
talk that jing was giving he had
independent adjacency mattresses in
different layers so
so most of the talks that means the
works that has been done works under
this format where you have this alpha
equals to zero
now of course when alpha increases then
essentially what you are having is that
all the adjacency metrics are remaining
the same so although you have say t
different layers but essentially you
have just one adjacency matrix
so if alpha equals to one
so now we are
expanding the situations that it can it
is somewhere in between
so there can be an independent dependent
situation this is the simplest form of
dependence we could think about
but even analyzing the simplest form of
dependence was also not so easy
because most of the conventional methods
didn't work
so
i mean you could have done something
where you each edge gets flipped in the
third places property alpha in each step
yes that can be also another way to deal
with each each edge gets clear yes here
you either you forget the whole network
or your key
yeah yeah either i forget the whole
thing or i keep but if you feel that i
just i remember some part of it some
part i forget yeah
so it's a bit different kind of thing
but yeah but
i i cannot say about the flipping one
but uh that how how hard the analysis
will be but this one also means yeah we
have to give some effort to do the
analysis
yeah but yeah those kind of simple
mechanisms can be there to go from the
independent setup to the dependency
so for this one uh what we first try to
do is the this kind of
step we first wanted to see that if you
do then aggregated adjacency matrix or
aggregated laplacian matrix based on
these layers
do they concentrate do they concentrate
to their mean
so that's the first thing we wanted to
try because this kind of results
concentration to their mean
concentration to their expectation are
used this kind of results are used for
community detection change point
detection all of different things this
kind of concentration is used and we try
to see the concentration in the spectral
node
so what we essentially show
that
okay this kind of
dependent format if you form the ah
aggregated adjacency matrix or the
aggregated laplacian matrix
in that case they are
near to the
they are concentrated around their
expectation or the mean version
and that expectation is controlled ah
first of all by t and t here is the
number of adjacency matrix you have
d max and d mean are the minimum of the
degrees of all the adjacency matrices
and this c 1 alpha is the one that con
that contains alpha
and this c 1 alpha and c 2 alpha are
actually both of the order of
of the order of 1 by square root of 1
minus alpha so as you can see in this
kind of a
in this setup that as alpha approaches
0 in that case this becomes this red
becomes like square root of t d max
however this 1 by square root of 1 minus
alpha starts becoming larger and larger
as alpha starts going near 1.
so as you can see
it's very intuitive here also we can see
that as alpha starts going near one that
means
uh we have the just one adjacency matrix
data is reducing so our concentration
becomes more and more difficult
and when alpha is trying to go to zero
we have better concentration because we
have many data many independent copies
of the data so our concentration becomes
better
so that's what we are capturing here and
the rate we are coming up which is of
the order of 1 by square root of 1 minus
alpha
so that's the rate we get and for both
laplacian and adjacency the difference
is that because one is laplacian and
another is adjacency
one is controlled by d max and other is
controlled by one by dv so that's the
effect of the laplacian and adjacency
so now we have a result for this kind of
situation now
ah
as i said means we have c1 alpha and c2
alpha of both of the order of 1 by
square root of 1 minus alpha so when
alpha equals to 0 the concentration is
the highest the best kind of
concentration we are getting because we
are adding up all of the adjacency
matrices
whereas for uh alpha
going to one the concentration becoming
worse and worse ultimately you have no
concentration because you have just one
data point
now
uh
none of the
known techniques that means matrix one
strand types combinatorial arguments
path counting arguments none of those
words for here we had to use a sort of a
geometric random variable kind of
argument here to prove this kind of
concentration result and the large
deviation result on that
so uh
and so by this actually we can capture
this whole range from very weakly
correlated network layers to strongly
correlated networks layers all we can
here
account for
by using this concentration inequality
so now of course uh
as we can see here this is in the
simulation results we can see that the
errors that are there in the this is the
spectral norm errors uh as alpha
increases they also increase in both
adjacency and laplacian matrices
these are two
in the
in the bottom you have two different
graph
networks networks generation from
continuous graphs and on the top you
have networks generated from stochastic
block products for both of the kind of
situations you have this kind of
concentration behavior
now then we can use this kind of
concentration results to do both
change point detection and community
detection where you have dependent
networks
so for change point detection we
consider the simple situation where you
have one single change point
so at certain time point you have you
have the expectation of the adjacency
matrix is q1 and it changes to q2 at
certain time point and you want to
capture that
and you can try to do that means the
main
main signal here is the spectral norm of
q1 and q2 here
so all the results will be in terms of
that spectral norm
and you can just use a single point
change point detection method where you
find the queue some statistic on one
part of the uh sequence and do some
statistics on the other part of the
sequence and then just take the
difference and where the difference is
maximized is the change point
so that's the simple single change point
detection method
and the statistic that we are using in
order to find the differences in q sum
is
this kind of a statistic where we are
scaling this q some statistic using this
scaling factor the scaling factor is
controlled by this ah z parameter which
usually people take as half many of the
times
but it can be changed in different
situations so our general result we just
kept in the side parameter here
so in our general parameter result we
could see that of course this how good
the estimate of the change point is
depend on the signal
uh
but it also depends on
this square root of one minus alpha
parameter
so
not only that it's the
usually the main results that we get
without the adjacency this kind of
dependence is that this one minus alpha
parameter is not there now this extra
once 1 by square root of 1 minus alpha
parameter is there while we are finding
the rates
and that's capturing the
dependence across the network layers
actually
so
this login term that comes here this
login term is an extra term we don't
think that it should be there in this
rate but this was the best we could do
in our analysis for now but i think a
better analysis probably will get rid of
this login term
and another thing i should mention is
that it's still in our this
concentration result
uh it's still under the uh under this
degree assumptions that td max have to
be greater than log n or poly log n
so this is
we also think that this can be relaxed
if we can
properly do the analysis or some other
ways
but this is for now this is what we can
get
and similarly for uh
[Music]
this is the qsum procedure and
similarly we can do community detection
also where we have a sequence of uh
network layers
but we have the same community structure
but the
adjacency matrixes are are dependent on
each other that kind of things can go on
so in that kind of a situation we can
also
estimate the unknown community
membership matrix using spectral
clustering either using the spectral
clustering on adjacency or laplacian
both will give you ah
you can bound the misclustering errors
here and in both situations the factor
of 1 by square root of 1 minus alpha
will be the extraneous one that will
come in the rate
so
that's
the first portion that you have
dependency network layers but the
dependence is coming from the dependency
in adjacency matrices
the second one we go so this is also the
simulation result for
sbm that means for community detection
the same thing we can see that as alpha
increases
you have worse and worse errors
for different situations
so
next we go for the situation where there
can be dependence in network
layer model parameters so that means
that here the situation you is that you
have two different graphs adjacent there
are adjacency matrix corresponding to
them
but these adjacency matrices are being
generated that means they have a mean
say which say we are calling that as pt
but this pt follows a stochastic process
so the network model parameters are the
ones that are dependent on each other
they are the ones that are following a
dependence pattern
so this is a bit different because here
the adjacency matrix they are still
conditionally independent
once you are you know pt
all the adjacency matrices are
conditionally independent of each other
but
ah this pt can be dependent on each
other so the dependence is coming from
the model parameters
so
uh
so
then
we can try to see that okay in this kind
of a setup uh if we have this kind of a
sequences of
network bundle parameters and also we
have
the adjacency matrix which is
being generated from that but we are
assuming here that the community
membership matrix
the community membership matrix is
something that is remaining constant
not changing and we are trying to find
that community membership matrix
so
just like uh
gene was mentioning in the previous talk
you can use the squared adjacency matrix
here in this kind of a situation
so we also took the similar one
but yeah but we did this long back
so
we took the same similar kind of squared
adjacency matrix but we took out the
diagonal
so
the method means the community detection
algorithm was that we took the sum of
the squared adjacency matrices
and then
in the squared adjacency matrices
uh
first of all we had to take out the
diagonal we took out the diagonal and
then not only that we try to get rid of
the large degree nodes
so among the in the adjacency matrix
because that's the one that creates
problem in concentration of the
adjacency matrices towards their mean so
what we did was that we took out the
high degree nodes and we had two
different thresholds based on both the
maximum degrees and also the mean
degrees
we had two different threshold based on
that we took out the ah
[Music]
we took out the high degree nodes
and once we took out the high degree
nodes we had this adjacency matrices
which was thresholded that means idd
nodes are gone
and also the diagonal is not there in
this kind of a situation if we try to ah
do a spectral clustering on this new
threshold matrix and we can try to use
the results of the spectral clustering
to find
ah
to find an estimate of the unknown
community membership
so here we are doing two different
operations we are taking out the
diagonal as well as we are thresholding
the high degree nodes thresholding them
so once you do that what we see the kind
of result that we see is that
in this kind of a situation
first of all
of course you need a condition on
the smallest eigen value of the sum of b
square matrices because that's the eigen
gap
that contains the main information about
whether the clusterable structure is
there or not
and then along with that we see an
interesting structure here is that
a nice interplay between the number of
layers and the degree of the
degrees of each of the networks so what
we see is that if the degree of the
network the maximum degree if that is
greater than 1 in that case
independent of whether
n is large or small you still have this
kind of a concentration
with a rate of td
to the power of minus 1 depending on
[Music]
and so
in in the situations where you have n
small it is determined by td and when n
is large uh also tb controls this rate
now in the situation of
d less than equals to 1 this red differs
in that it is dependent on td square
instead of td
so this rate on which the number of
layers are related that changes from
whether it is related as
in proportional to 1 over c or in
proportional to 1 over square root of t
depending on the situation depending on
whether
you have what's the interplay between
the number of nodes in the network and
the number of layers in the network
but this is for independent layers
now if the layers were dependence if the
layers were not independent
in that kind of a situation of course we
have to consider a stochastic process
now instead of considering a stochastic
process on the b matrix what we consider
here the most important thing actually
is the smallest eigen value of b
so instead of that we consider the
stochastic process on the smallest eigen
value of b
so if means
and also on the maximum degree variable
which is also a random variable so we
considered stochastic process on these
two and what we considered were
we considered a mixing condition on this
smallest eigen value the smallest eigen
value process of the b stochastic
process so this mixing condition is
needed to control the rate of the
adjacency of this concentration of the
adjacency matrices
so we consider the missing alpha mixing
condition on this smaller whether this
smallest eigenvalue takes a value of 0
or not based on that stochastic process
and then also
we try to see so in the assumptions
ultimately we try to control for
a function of this t and d such that
this t d function is there to control
for this kind of a situation that means
what is the
probability that smallest eigenvalue
takes a value of 0. so we want that
probability to go smaller and smaller as
tg goes to infinity we don't want this
to happen because if this happens there
will be no community finding
there will be no community structure so
we want this probability to be lower and
lower as td increases
and we want to capture that using this
five function and also we want that this
expectation of this phi is controlled
expectation of this lambda
the smallest eigenvalue process is
controlled under this kind of a
condition this assumptions conditions we
can again show that
the amount of mistakes we are making
making in this squared adjacency matrix
based community detection spectral
clustering we can control the amount of
uh the
amount of errors that we are making and
of course that depends on the stochastic
process mainly the smallest eigenvalue
of the stochastic process and the degree
parameters so this tdn
tdm and tdn square this parameters as
well as
the
smallest
the lambda kt the parameters of that
smallest eigenvalue process
based on that we can show that it
converges that means you have a
consistency in the network community
membership identification
so
i will i will skip this change point for
problem formulation uh for this kind of
dependent uh model parameter setup
instead of that uh let me just go into
uh
this one this detour also i will skip
in the interest of time so in this
detour i consider the situation where
even for sparse metrics you can
determine the number of communities
consistently using a variation of the
bethesian matrices which previously khan
and lisa used
so i will skip that portion also the one
thing that i wanted to mention another
form of dependence as i was saying is
depend networks with dependent age
structure
now in this kind of a system as i was
saying that networks we usually want
networks to have this kind of
nice desirable properties that means
sparsity small world property power law
degree distribution transitivity and
presence of a low rank structure or
community structure so this kind of five
different different desirable properties
we usually want
but many of the times the models that we
consider like say the uh
the exchangeable network model that we
consider that usually that usually can
means that cannot have these five
properties simultaneously
if you try to take four one will be
missing many of the times
so that's why in this kind of a setup
specifically say if you try to get a
sparse transitive and low rank matrices
from graphone models you cannot really
get that because of the exchangeability
property
so that's why what we considered was a
very simple extension
was this what we called as transitive in
homogeneous solid graph or a transitive
expansion of the exchangeable random
graph models
where after we
had at the first step we will get and
from an exchangeable model we will get a
network in homogeneous seduction e
networks or
an exchangeable model network
we are here considering very simple
situation that we have a p matrix which
is generating the
network at the zeroth step and we have a
triangle closure parameter of delta n
which is just one parameter this is the
simplest case this can be expanded of
course and we are repeating this process
k number of times that means
that's what we are calling as a tire k
model that means we have starting from
step 0
and at each of the steps what we are
doing is we are doing a triangle closure
we are taking two different nodes we are
seeing whether these two different nodes
have any common neighbors or not if they
have even one common neighbor we will
form an edge between these two nodes
with probability delta so that is the
triangle closure operation
and after we have an inhomogeneous
shadow stranding graph or exchangeable
network model graph
we will first try to form
close all the triangles that we can that
will give us a tier 1 model then we will
take that network and then again try to
do triangle closure that will give us
the tire two model and so on and on
so we will
repeat this k number of times in a tier
k model but in a tier one model we will
do this just once
so
and
the idea is that within using this
triangle closure you can get all five
properties that you can that you want
from an
extending from the exchangeable network
model so just to show you
uh
some some
simulated results at least so here we
can see that in this kind of situation
this is generated from sbm
the
network is sparse uh in in in this kind
of a situation
and in the case we when we are doing
tire one two three also that infarct is
still remaining sparse the average
degree is still like varying between one
to two but the
uh but the number of triangles they are
increasing la hugely so this is for sbm
model the number of triangles is almost
close to zero of course we are
normalizing it
but it is increasing step by step when
we are going from tier one to three
similarly when we are considering
geodesics the graphs are becoming
smaller and smaller world properties are
coming
and also the eigen gaps are increasing
that means you are having a
more a more more
nicer low rank structure so all of these
are going on when you are introducing
the tire structure in the exchangeable
networks
and
later on we try to use that for
different this different kinds of
problems sub graph count distribution
community detection change point
detection many of the works are ongoing
some of the works are close to finish
and some of the works we are published
submitting so yeah so a huge number of
works here uh i will not go into the
example of change point detection
anymore we don't have time for that
and
many there are many future directions
here as we can see that extension of the
tire k models
uh extending the dependent setup of the
dependency adjacency matrices i used a
very simple setup
variation
of this community levels over time which
i didn't consider my community levels
were remaining constant throughout the
time
and also how to incorporate covariance
so all of these are mean good future
directions last an advertisement that we
have openings if you have students or
you are a student you are encouraged
and yeah some of the references thank
you for listening
oh
so for the third talk today i see this
interesting theme that um
peter hinted at in his question earlier
today
so we saw that
local information in the sense of you
know neighbors or neighbors of neighbors
something like that is helpful then we
saw in
uh jing's talk that squaring the
adjacency matrix seems to help we see
that again here
something is going on here where looking
at like squaring the adjacency matrix is
really just looking at
two hop information instead of one you
can see that actually in the result also
here in the description
can you can you speak to that a little
bit
so here actually you can see that so it
is depending on both td square and td
td is just the connection that means
what is the probability of an edge
formation
because it's taking into account the
number of times and the degree whereas
td square is that hop that means number
of common neighbors
so if td square is dominating
means depending on the how the adjacency
matrix has been from if td square is
dominating then that is the one that is
dominating the rate that means number of
common neighbors you have but if td is
dominating in that case td is dominating
the result
in that case so there is an interaction
goes on here between the number of
common neighbors you have and the number
of
edges you have between two
to two different vertices
so yeah the number of common neighbors
plays a huge role here and that's why
you have this
separation in the rates the amount of
errors that you are making
so
yeah
okay
speaker again
[Applause]
our second speaker is
now working north international man she
got this phd from berkeley